[Musique]
pink mobilité est une entreprise qui
développe qui produit et commercialise
des scooters électriques nous existons
depuis 2016 et nous avons trois marchés
principaux premièrement le marché de la
livraison du dernier kilomètre c'est les
pizzas les sushis voilà le deuxième
marché c'est le marché de la mobilité
partagée le scooter en libre-service
est le troisième marché c'est le marché
des particuliers dans nos gammes de
scooter on a aussi un scooter pour le
consul pour le libre service et on a
conçu ce scooter là et on l'amélioré
depuis plus de trois ans c'est mon cas
prend maintenant pour cette société qui
s'appelle diego
[Musique]
le premier poste et jonathan qu'il tient
ici on fait tout ce qui est câblage vers
l'installation mécanique sur le scooter
et liaison avec tous les câbles du
scooter le deuxième poste
est un poste vrai manque les dents sur
la ligne de production c'est un poste
sur lequel on veut continuer de monter
certains composants électroniques il
faut savoir que cet hymne de production
la dame dès cet été pour produire
jusqu'à 30 scooter par jour on vient
vérifier également faire les tests
électroniques pour vérifier que tout
fonctionne clignotant les feux klaxon
etc seront bien effectué tous les
contrôles mécanique du scooter donc
vérifier le serrage au couple d
des ags deux roues ont bien monté les
bernier carénage du scooter
fixer les rétroviseurs le support de
téléphone m les casques dans le caisson
arrière quand on roule en électrique on
a vraiment cette sensation un peu de
voix là de liberté parce qu'on n'est pas
polluer ni par l'odeur ni par le bruit
du moteur ni par les vibrations avec un
scooter électrique vous avez la batterie
à payer donc la batterie ça coûte plus
cher qu'un réservoir d'essence vide vous
allez investir un peu plus au départ
mais derrière vous n'allez rien payer ni
en essence vous allez payer beaucoup
moins cher en entretien on a des villes
qui sont de plus en plus congestionnées
il ya deux pleins d'embouteillage et
c'est donc évidemment c'est plus c'est
plus efficient et c'est plus valorisant
de se dire que ont conduit un produit
qui est plus efficient qui moins polluer
si on est par hasard bloqué dans un
embouteillage et bien on n'émet aucune
particule
[Musique]